residents of the state of Georgia can  now claim embryos as dependents on their  tax returns and I have to tell you I'm  pro-choice  a hundred percent but if you're going to  be anti-choice on the basis that an  embryo or a fetus is a person then be  consistent child support for the embryo  or fetus absolutely a dependent on the  tax return you should be able to take  the child tax credit uh what about all  of the other things that a person gets  I'm against all of this wacky stuff  including what's going on in Georgia but  if you're going to say that an embryo or  a fetus is a person then you should be  able to claim it as such on your tax  returns